قالت وزاره الاعلام الصوماليه ان خمسه
مدنيين قتلوا واصيبوا اربعه كما قتل جميع
مسلحي حركه الشباب السته في هجوم على مكتب
رئيس بلديه بلديه بالعاصمه السومريه
مقديشه وقالت مصادر حكوميه ان الاجهزه
الامنيه انهت العمليه وقد وجنى مقاتل حركه
الشباب وهزوما بداوه بتفجير عاقبه اقتحام
ومقر البلديه
وقال متحدث باسم حركه الشباب عبد العزيز
ابو مصعب بين مقاتلي الحركه اقتحم مقر
البلديه بعد قتل افراد قوات الامن
معنا من مقديشي الجزيره جامع النور جامع
ابن حسب المعلومات المتوفره ما الذي انتهت
اليه هذه العمليه
عثمان اخر تصريح للحكومه الصوماليه وخاصه
المتحدث باسم الشرطه الصوماليه هو ذكر
مقتل 11 شخصا في هذا الهجوم سته منهم من
المهاجمين من حركه الشباب بينما الخمسه
الباقون من المدنيين الذين كانوا متواجدين
في المكان ومن بين اييه من قتل في هذا
الهجوم يبقى بعض المصادر التي نحصل عليها
همم
مدير قسم همم قسم المعاقين في بلديه
مقديشه الذي قيل انه قتل في في مكتبه في
في مقر بلديه العاصمه المتحدث باسم الشرطه
الصوماليه ذكر ان قضت الاجهزه الامنيه
الصوماليه التي كانت تحرس همم بلديه
العاصمه حاله دون وقوعي ضحايا كثر حيث
استطاعت الاجهزه الامنيه همم معظم من
كانوا في همم مقر البلديه اثناء وقوع
الهجوم كان من بينهم همم النواب من همم
نعرف انهم ما همم بعمده العاصمه له اكثر
من نائب في في اداره البلديه فكان هناك
عدد من النواب همم عمده العاصمه متواجدين
في المكان وقد تم اجلاء لهم خلال وقوع هذا
الانفجار بالاضافه الى عدد كبير من همم
الموظفين الذين كانوا يعملون داخل مقر
البلديه عثمان استمرت المواجهات لفتره
طويله بما يقارب مثلا ست ساعات بين
المهاجمين الذين حصلوا داخل همم مقر بلديه
العاصمه وبين الاجهزه الامنيه التي طوقت
المكان وكان يحدث بين الحين والاخر
تفجيرات داخل مقر البلديه همم مقر البلديه
يقع في مكان محصن وهناك تحصينات والنقاط
تفتيش قبل الوصول الى هذه النقطه بعض
المراقبين يتحدثون ان همم ربما خللا ما في
همم
او الصخره امنيه في حمايه امن العاصمه
استغلتها حركه الشباب للوصول الى هذا
المكان
المحصن بشكل كبير اا ال- ال- الملفت ان
عمده العاصمه لم يكن موجوده هو الاخر
اثناء وقوع هذا الهجوم فهو في زياره الى
خارج
البلد كما ورد في الخبر حركه الشباب هي
تمام المسؤوليه وقال المتحدث باسمها ان
عناصر من مقاتله من نفضه هذا الهجوم وهنا
يتبين رويدا تبين رويدا رويدا ما ذكرناه
في النشراتنا سابقه من ان ربما الهجوم
البداء الذي افتتحت به حركه الشباب هذا
الهجوم كان هجوم هجوم لشخصين من هؤلاء
السته الذين هاجموا
بحزمه ناسفه عاقبه بعد ذلك اقتحام للعناصر
المتبقيه ويبدو ان اربعه من هؤلاء كانوا
يتحسنون داخل المبنى ويواجهون الاجهزه
امنيه داخل همم مقر بلديه العاصمه هذا
الهجوم هو ياتي بعد ثلاث سنوات تقريبا
بعدها لهجوم مماثل راح ضحيته عمده العدس
العاصمه
حيث استطاعت حركه الشباب زرع قنبله داخل
احدى القاعات المقر همم بلديه العاصمه ما
ادى الى مقتل عمده العاصمه وعدد من
المسؤولين الذين كانوا يتواجدون فيها اهل
ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك من مقديشه مراسل
الجزيره جامعه نوره